advice for women dating in their early
20s
don't sleep with people right
not unless that is a serious
serious relationship and if you're
hooking up or dating someone and they're
like yeah i don't really want to get
married
just dump them who cares about that
person like and if you think that you're
going to date them and then change them
into someone who does want to get
married they kind of sound like a loser
to begin with that or like sit them down
and have a very serious conversation and
ask questions like do you ever want to
get married okay well if you do when do
you want to get married and make sure
that your dreams align with their dreams
because if you're dating somebody and
they don't have any plan on getting
married then you're wasting your time
and that's trickier for women because
women are most attractive and most
fertile when they're young and men i
would say get more attractive you know
in their mid 30s maybe even 40s so
they have time that you don't have